so you now have this mapping
between all of the set of functions that
could all
encode the same all of the set of
sequences that can all encode the same
function
what evolutionary signatures does is
that it basically looks at
the shape of that distribution of
sequences that all encode the same thing
and based on that shape you can
basically say oh proteins have a very
different shape
than rna structures than regulatory
motifs etc so just by scanning a
sequence
ignoring the sequence and just looking
at the patterns of change
i'm like wow this thing is evolving like
a protein and that thing is evolving
like a motif and that thing is evolving
so that's exactly what we just did for
covid
so our paper that we posted about
archive about coronavirus
basically took this concept of
evolutionary signatures
and applied it on the sarsko v2 genome
that is responsible for the carbon-19
pandemic uh and
comparing it to 44 cerbicovirus species
so this is
the beta did you just use cervical
arbitravirus cesars related beta
coronavirus it's a porpointo so that one
family of viruses
yeah so is that family by the way we
have 44 species
that or 24 species in the fam yeah
viruses are clever but
no no but but there's just 44 and again
we don't call them species
in in viruses we call them strains but
anyway there's 44 strains
and that's a tiny little subset of you
know maybe another 50 strains that are
just far too decently related
most of those only infect bats
as the host and a subset of only four or
five
have ever infected humans and we
basically took all of those and we
aligned them
in the same exact way that we've aligned
mammals and then we looked at
what proteins are you know which of the
currently hypothesized genes
for the coronavirus genome are in fact
evolving like proteins and which ones
are not
and what we found is that orf10 the last
little
open reading frame the last little gene
in the genome is bogus
that's not a protein at all what is it
it's an rna structure
that doesn't have a it doesn't get
translated into amino acids
and that's so it's important to narrow
down to basically
discover what's useful and what's not
exactly basically what are what is even
the set of genes
the other thing that these evolutionary
signatures showed is that within
or 3a lies a tiny little additional gene
encoded within the other gene
so you can translate a dna sequence in
three different reading frames
if you start in the first one it's you
know atg et cetera if you start on the
second one is tgc etc
and with there's a there's a gene within
a gene
so there's a whole other protein that we
didn't know about that might be super
important
so we don't even know the building
blocks of sarsko v2
so if we want to understand coronavirus
biology and eventually find it
successfully
we need to even have the set of genes
and and these evolutionary signatures
that are developed in my phd work are
you really
you know what let's uh let's run with
that tangent for a little bit if it's
okay
uh is uh can we talk about
uh the the kovid 19 a little bit more
like how what's your sense about the the
genome
the proteins the functions that we
understand about
covet 19 where do we stand in in your
sense
what are the big open problems and also
you know you kind of said it's important
to understand what are the
like the the important proteins and
like why is that important
so what else does the
comparison of these species tell us what
it tells us is
how fast are things evolving it tells us
about
at what level is the acceleration or
deceleration pedal
set for every one of these proteins so
the genome has you know 30-some genes
some genes evolve super super fast
others evolve
super super slow if you look at the
polymerase gene that basically
replicates the genome that's a super
slow evolving one
if you look at the nuclear capsid
protein that's also super
slow evolving if you look at the spike
one protein
this is the part of the spike protein
that actually touches the h2 receptor
and then enables the virus to attach
to your cells that's the thing that
gives it that
that visual the corona look basically
yeah
so basically the spike protein sticks
out of the virus and there's a first
part of the protein s1
which basically attaches to the h2
receptor
and then s2 is the latch that sort of
pushes and channels the fusion of the
membranes and then the incorporation
of the viral rna
inside our cells which then gets
translated into all of these 30 proteins
so the s1 protein is evolving
ridiculously fast so if you look at
the stop professor's gas pedal the gas
pedal is all the way down
or eight is also evolving super fast and
or six is evolving super fast we have no
idea what they do
we have some idea but nowhere near what
s1 is
so what the isn't that terrifying that
is that means
that's a really useful function and if
it's evolving fast
doesn't that mean new strains could be
created or it does something that means
that it's searching for
how to match how to best match the host
so basically anything
in in general in evolution if you look
at genomes anything that's contacting
the environment
is evolving much faster than anything
that's internal and the reason is that
the environment changes
so if you look at the evolution of these
cervical viruses
the s1 protein has evolved very rapidly
because it's attaching to different
hosts
each time we think of them as bats but
there's thousands of species of bats
and to go from one species of bat to
another species of bat you have to
adjust
s1 to the new a2 receptor that you're
going to be facing in that new species
you